your uh last partner uh detective imenez
i never met him but i hear he
he left some pretty big shoes to fill
let's get one thing straight
you're never gonna fill him in as his
shoes ever
menace was a good man better cop
philly menace his shoes the tip of your
dick couldn't fill a
bottle cap crazy crazy
look at this mess makes me
sick there's no way to stop this kind of
insane violence
seems like no matter what we do some
innocent fool is always going to get
slaughtered and we're always gonna be
playing ketchup
we're never gonna find the guy that did
this
tell that to his widow
[Music]
and we're always going to be playing
catch-up we're never going to find the
guy that did this
it's a weird one nothing out of place
no murder weapon and no motive there's
uh just a couple
lying dead in their bed the proof is
always out there detectives you just
have to know where to find the pudding
excuse me sir you can't be here this is
a crime scene it's okay
he's the greatest sex crime investigator
in history
if it isn't detective chuck vaughn
detective sally ferguson we could use a
genius right now
tom samwell what have we got samwell
well uh vomit we've got ourselves a hard
case here
all we've got is two bodies both dead
naked one man one woman
in the bed two scented candles by the
nightstand how did you
no sign of forced entry he loved the way
they smelled
he wanted to cross the threshold the way
they had on their wedding day
you dirty dog
he would have experienced that pleasure
right here
anniversary a couple was together for a
while wanted to spice things up
check the date on the photograph
vaughn's right today was their 15th
wedding anniversary this is huge
and what the was that
you just pulled your dick out and
started jerking off
at the crime scene samwell he's the best
there is
by putting himself in the perpetrator's
mindset he's able to solve crimes that
involve sex
bag this up some call it a blessing
it's more like a curse is that what it
feels like
threesome
you wanted to see them didn't you you
wanted to watch
25 feet from the bedroom across from the
kitchen
you didn't want to see their flesh yet
did you
no he stood right here
[Applause]
role play gone wrong check the logs
hey we've got a bloody fire poker
we've got our murder weapon um
why do your revelations require
masturbation
why do kittens require milk no not the
same thing
hey hey he's the most brilliant goddamn
detective i know
put your ego aside and give vanna's
space my ego
we've got captain pudpuller flinging his
fluids all over the crime scene
wait he knew them
they they were close so close
too close he he
i think he knew the house
why what did you want you sick bastard
you wanted to see
what he saw every day only closer
closer
he was close to home
[Music]
there's our man all right let's go get
him
go go
vaughn that was amazing i'm sorry
that i doubted you your methods are
unorthodox but i cannot argue with your
results
no hard feelings uh no no not gonna do
that
johnny okay carter
i can stay here all night so why don't
you and i
cut the crap and you tell me what
happened
on march 15th and what's in it for
carter finley
what's in it for you is i don't send you
back to jail
[Music]
the guy's name is cat branchman i met
him downtown at a club called the
clutching kitten
you may have heard of it it's down on
the corner of
hang and fur street cat branchman
so what's a guy like you and a guy named
[Music]
cat
okay i know what you're doing finley
you're just using what you see in my
poster i'm not detective
i'm telling the truth we'll see how much
truth you tell after a few weeks in
solitary
fine detective you've twisted my arm
that's better the guy's name wasn't cat
branchman
it was a chinese guy named mr meow
he's the real gang boss story went he
hung
guys from trees and took pictures of
them finley
used to run a club downtown a front of
course
called it the paw and poster thinly
ran it with a guy named hong indar
okay
let's try this one more time
finley who do you work for
um coffee
mr coffee coop
coffee coop his name was baldi tall
man coffee coop now you're just talking
about me
finley i'm gonna give you one more
chance
who is in charge his name was
angry man the warehouse is located
in the diploma
for being a detective i want to name
justin thank you
hang true don't say hang god damn it do
not say hang
on hang nope hang man
justin cat finley poster
do not say poster or cat
cat poster okay that's it i'm losing my
patience
winslow get this [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
i'm losing my patience
let's try this one more time
getting too old for this
[Music]
well-played detective
[Music]
well-played indeed hey carter
you hang in there
hello you must be detective hobbs
i am your new partner joshua tay
um what you know uh your uh last partner
uh detective imenez i i never met him
but i hear he
he left some pretty big shoes to fill
let's get one thing straight
you're never gonna fill him in as his
shoes ever
menace was a good man better cop
philly men as his shoes the tip of your
dick couldn't fill a
bottle cap i'm i'm very sorry
if that came out wrong i'm sure jimenez
was a great cop the best
okay uh
so these uh prostitute murders um
seems like a serial killer could be um i
actually worked out a theory
i don't give a hobos hat about your
theory
you think jimenez worked off of theories
like some kind of a needle dick charles
darwin
not on your ass ximena's always
shot straight from the dick
you think you're a menace absolutely not
you're goddamn right you're not
i just said him hey menace would have
busted 20 perps in the time to take you
to
pull up your pants over your itsy bitsy
teeny weeny yellow polka dot but peepee
two daughters raising them on his own
you want that job
huh mr baby dick what is going on you
wanna be that daddy
no you know what i think i think we got
off on the wrong foot
90 minutes oh ximena's got off on the
right foot every goddamn day of his
goddamn life which is more than i can
say for your pebble penis having ass
he meant ximena's wannabe i can assure
you i don't want to be a menace why not
what's wrong with the menace there's
nothing wrong with them
and why wouldn't you want to be like i
don't know you said pekka
okay i'm out i can't i can't make this
work
man has would have made it work
[Music]
come back from florida soon jimenez
first things first i do not care that
you're a multi-platinum selling rapper
gun rack
what i care about is that i 100 know
that you murdered darnell simmons so
you better start talking
[Music]
yeah but you ain't got nothing okay
i you know i'm actually i'm very glad
that you said that
uh because i respectfully i beg to
differ
i killed darnell yeah i shot him with my
nine
i shot him nine times nine pm on the
dime
and by the way it was november night
that don't mean nothing
i got a vivid imagination
i couldn't have sat down now i was at my
cousin's birthday party
red lobster november 9. at
red lobster geez i got to tell you gun
right
i find that really hard to believe
i got an alibi red lobster
when in reality i shot darnell like a
mobster
it's a lot anyone could tell this if you
know about my allergy to all shelby
just confess conrad i
confess that shellfish is the only thing
that rhymes with tell this
it's just worse
now's adjectives they just happen to be
in a dope order but
we ain't got no pearl
shut up darnell with a long-ass
[Music]
i have no idea what that object is
if i had to identify it i would call it
a gun of the long ass variety
some seaweed in there too look detective
i hate to break it to you i ain't
killing my money
i struck my chin real slow when i'm
lying
and i was laughing super hard as darnell
was dying
the name of the album is i killed
darnell simmons it's a concept i want a
concept
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and behind you
it's terrible shipment's body
why is enough you're going away for a
long time you understand
you're going to confess if it's the last
thing you'll ever do you hear me don't
wreck
i'll be somebody i'll beat out
he's free to go what no no no no no we
have everything we need
no it was simmons girlfriend she just
confessed to the whole thing
infidelity crime of passion
let's go mr rack
[Music]
and when you let me out i'm gonna blow a
little kiss
this is my confession he missable in
court
i killed darnell simmons for sport
that's right i'm a murderer come get me
come down the hall you can't get me okay
okay okay you got me
you got me hey what what damn damn ow
[Music]
[Music]
i
ow